[Applause]
well welcome back
uh you know to say that somebody is your
hero
doesn't sound right when it's a she but
the word heroin it's just never settled
with me so let's just let's just settle
and say
ivy zellman is a hero of mine uh
i was largely the running joke inside
the fed was that they hired me to shut
up about the housing market that was
going to crash
in 2005 and i was very unpopular but
there was somebody who was even more
unpopular
and in a good way because she protected
she protected all of her clients she
protected the broader investing
community so i'm so so so pleased to
bring
to you today ivy zellman zellman
has her own her own research company she
has for years
but she's a legend on wall street and
um before we get into kind of the cv
if you will i'm going to share a
personal anecdote with you
and with ivy that is likely to blow
ivy's mind
so when i was uh 16 i was a young
graduate of high school
and when i was 16 i was accepted to the
nyu
uh scholars program for journalists in
new york
that was my great dream to go back to
new york i had family in connecticut
uh and they were going to pay for half
of of my college and i went
running into my father's office and i
said dad dad i've been accepted and
they're going to cover
half and we only have to cover half them
the first summer i get to go to
russia and every summer i get to travel
it's my dream come true oh my gosh
and he said well i haven't really filed
my taxes for the last decade or so
and there's no applying for financial
aid and you might want to consider
community college
and so at the ripe old age of 16 my
dreams were kind of dashed uh i probably
i probably didn't speak to my dad much
after that and uh because
he ruined our family's finances but i
did start off at san antonio
college and i eventually ended up
getting my
my master's in austin in finance and
a few weeks in i was invited by a
company by the name of solomon brothers
that i'd never heard of
to go up for an informational interview
i said god this finance stuff sounds
fascinating so two weeks later two weeks
into my
mba program i'm staring out at a
two-story tall
trading floor and i count it one two
three four five six seven
women who were probably sales assistants
at the time
and said to myself god if a woman can
make it here she can make it
anywhere and i was bound and determined
to get on wall street
and i did and i
attribute some of my success to how i
had to start out
my college career and when you
shared with me kind of your background i
have to say
i had to pick myself up off the floor so
now you can go and explain to us uh how
there might be a few parallels in that
story
well first thank you so much for having
me it's great to be a guest
on your show i'm excited and uh i too am
totally admit and totally admiring your
success and everything that you've done
um at the fed and you and i had met back
at thinking oh nine right
crossed paths then um but anyway it's
great to
be on your show with not having another
professional successful woman
there's not too many of us out there so
we gotta stick together
well my story um definitely has a lot of
parallels um when i was
about 16 17 my dad rocked our world
unfortunately his career which was
extremely successful
international banker we were in london
for three years when i was 12 to 15
he came back to new york and
unfortunately
things from his uh role at his company
midland
um london america it was called and he
wound up losing
his job and so we had unfortunately too
much money we made similar to you where
his tax returns showed that we were not
going to
in fact qualify for student for any type
of financial aid so i was pretty much on
my own and i wound up going to a city
college in new york called baruch
and working full-time actually for a
company that he a home healthcare
company he started and um after
a year or so at um night school in the
city which i loved it was a lot of fun
you know our campus was new york city i
fell in love
and um you know you do a lot of things
when you fall in love and i met a young
man from northern virginia and i moved
to northern virginia
parents were totally against it but went
there and um started out at
what's called nova a community college
like yourself
and after two years and working
full-time um going to night school
i transferred to george mason and all in
finished my undergrad
of in six years and had a bunch of
student loans
and then really was working my last
two years i think i worked at arthur
young which have been now is ernst young
and i was an administrative assistant
and i kept asking everyone at work there
do you like your job i'm majoring in
accounting because that was what my dad
did and
figured i'd get a job that way and
they're like oh you don't want to be an
accountant it's like the worst job ever
which kind of you know blew up my whole
um
future i wasn't sure where the hell i
was going to go and they said go to wall
street
so i started just networking and it
wasn't that easy so pretty much anyone i
could meet within
arthur young or anyone at my gym i just
started talking to people and eventually
got
a in interview at solomon brothers but
before that interview at solomon which
the partner and arthur young actually
helped me because we were their auditors
to get that interview
i actually went and had an information
interview similar to yours
um with um merrill ish and that was a
friend through the gym
that got me in there and he was great
and he was actually fixed income he was
a vp in dick sitcom
and the first thing he said to me is um
you know do you have any other
you know um interviews scheduled on wall
street i was very proud yeah i have an
interview with sally
um later today he was really tell me
about solomon brothers
and so i knew from reading the ten you
know at the time going the library
reading the annual report
well the ceo's john gut friend he goes
john good friend and then he started
going through this rant about everything
solomon's the brains merrill's the
muscle
and he just and then at the end of the
interview he's like where's your journal
are they in is there a tombstone is
there any tombstone of solomon today
and i'm looking through my briefcase and
i have like my international marketing
notes i'm studying for
and i go i don't have a journalist you
better get your ass out here get a wall
street journal and see if solomon
brothers has any tombstones today
so i'm feverishly in the cafeteria at
maryland she grabbed a paper
and sure enough there was a ups uh
senior 200 million
senior note offering that sally did and
so when i had my interview with sally it
they
went really well oh solomon's you know
the brains and
meryl's the muscle and i was repeating
some of the things that cj said to me
and then at the end of the interview i
said oh by the way congratulations i see
that sally did a
um 200 million senior note offering and
the guy he has
touched his chest and he's like that was
my deal
and he's like that was my deal and i go
wow
and that was it got the offer so worked
in their
investment awesome for two years and i
was one of three women
out of 70. and um it was quite
intimidating and most of
everyone there excluding myself was
either at top schools or ivy league
schools
a lot of them were poets so they really
weren't
um familiar with accounting and finance
because they wanted
young people that could really think and
so in the classroom with
you know this we had a six week training
program you know i was raising my hand
all the time and
it turns out that a lot of these kids
where i was so intimidated by them
they later you know 15 years later like
god you really intimidated the out
of us i'm like
really i'm like i was so totally
overwhelmed and communicated by you so
anyway that was my first two years prior
to moving into research
and just really quick i figured i'd go
back and get my mba because 90
of the kids that are in this program 70
kids they usually get two years
under their belt they get their mba and
so i
got my gmats i went did my essays and
applied to harvard stanford and
northwestern and i said you know what
if i can't get into one of the three
best i already have student loans
i'm not going to go get my mba and i got
rejected from all three
so i was pretty deflated and then i just
started looking internally for a job
and solomon as you remember had the big
treasury scandal right around that time
in 91
and john's good friend was out and derek
moan was in and we had
a lot of people that thought solomon was
going to have their lights go out that
they
were they were going to make it and who
was in charge of
at treasury who was the man in charge of
this at treasury
trivial pursuit jake powell j powell oh
my god
that's right powell was the guy who who
was charged at he was he was
under secretary at treasury at the time
and his job was solomon brown
anyway we're in a small world very small
world so
i just started looking for a job and um
the analyst that covered
airlines because i was in the
transportation group that's where i got
my job in corporate finance
he helped me get an opportunity to work
as an associate under the
snl fannie freddie analyst bruce harding
and everyone said oh you don't want to
go work in research those are people
just monkeys they just do whatever the
management they write whatever
managements tell them to
and i just need to pay my rent so i was
just happy to get a job
and that 30 years later here i am so
that's how i got into equity research
and
following housing i actually did get out
through the
uh and the mba training program when
solomon their credit the director of
research realized that i was a little
over my head
i didn't have the experience or maybe
the knowledge that i needed to really be
an analyst and they decided they would
take me
out of the role as an associate now
being given the home
builders and the housing stocks in
general and go to the mba training
program that liars poker was written
about
so that was pretty cool and i and i was
intimidated because those people were
coming in and they knew their finance so
it was a little different
but it was a lot of fun um those were
the good old days
yeah my first night in the nba training
program
i met liar i i read i didn't sleep i
read lyrics poker all night long
because i was the only person who hadn't
read it um
so uh you mentioned snl
uh if you can
i mean you weren't really active in the
industry at the time but
there was back then a market clearing
a true market clearing yes
and um so hold that thought hold that
thought if you will
so you're you're a full-blown housing
analyst i mean you're in the eye polls
you're
you're out there you're competing you're
in the trenches
yes um when
when did you sense the presence if you
will
of of alan greenspan or did you ever
and his measured approach to
raising interest rates and the follow-on
effect that this was having
in the housing market well my first
memory
is february um 94.
i think that was when we first had the
fed at that time wasn't
um providing a lot of transparency you
know when they changed
rates at fomc meeting that's when we
knew it was happening
and i remember that period we had i
think
in 94 it was probably seven in a row
tightenings oh yeah and it rocked my
world because
at that time i didn't appreciate the
importance to what the
equities in the housing stocks generally
speaking anything tied to housing
we're just completely inversely related
to the rates backing up and so i
actually
publish a report completely wrong you
know the battle between fundamentals and
psychology
meaning that you know housing could
withstand a backup and rate so that was
my first memory of him
and interestingly a decade later alan
greenspan
um in february 04 um i guess that's
two decades later right um i don't know
one one later
decade sorry so i remember in february
four
when he said it's okay to get an arm and
that's when the market went
haywire i remember that and that was
like okay
so you no longer you know really touting
a 30-year fixed mortgage rate and that
was the beginning
of permission to the mortgage industry
to go out there and start these exotic
mortgage products so
um somewhat interesting that it's here
it was a decade later
it was and of course at the time who was
running the san francisco fed and all of
this was happening in her backyard
well our friends yes indeed that's why
that's why i've got this this lovely
hashtag on twitter hashtag j and jade
amd in between so i don't get sued by
johnson johnson um
so you saw what was coming
um i mean i i'll never forget i was in i
was in a clo meeting
at credit suisse in 2001 and a bunch of
investment bankers up at the front of
the room
and they're talking about this equity
tranche
and i'm back of the room you know just
making trouble who the hell would buy
that crap
of the equity trunch i asked years later
bloomberg businessweek had a front cover
story on that clo
and all of the shenanigans that had gone
on
in order to build it out all those years
ago but when
um there was a famous scene with you
and toll brothers yes and uh
and and what was it like i was friends
with david rosenberg i was friends with
john hatzius at the time
um mortgage equity withdrawal
house atm but what was it that struck
you
as being kind of well this is this is an
undeniable red flag
well fortunately for me i have built a
proprietary network
of industry executives c-suite
executives that are home builders
mortgage originators land developers
real estate brokers and over the years
you know
back in 2004 and five they were waiving
a lot of red flags they were saying that
you know the level of demand is not
sustainable builders are buying land
that
i can't pencil i can't justify the
returns the mortgage originators started
telling you about things like
um you'll remember countrywide's fast
and easy program where
you know basically i talked to a
mortgage i had lunch with and he said
yeah i just underwrote um a loan for a
log
student a law student grad and um and he
doesn't have a job yet but i let he
bought a house i said
how can you just how can you justify
underwriting someone without a job he's
like oh it doesn't matter i'll just sell
it to fannie freddie
it's you know and all of these things
that were
you know percolating coupled with the
data that we're
looking at on affordability and what we
really saw is that the primary buyer
had pretty much already started
decelerating in o4
and that all of the lift was coming from
investors
we actually published a piece in um july
of 0.5
that was called investors gone wild and
it was really laden with
the exotic mortgage products coupled
with the
a percent of investors that were going
in and purchasing with you know liar
loans and no money down so
i think that was really for us just red
flags everywhere and it was almost
too obvious and yet you had the industry
that was the cheerleaders and drinking
the kool-aid back to bob toll
where they were like you know the
demographics are you know
secular changes and home ownership rates
and this is sustainable
and they really genuinely most of them
believed it and that was really just
very much i was the sober person at the
party i was not
you know the fun person that was kind of
joining in the equities were all
you know continuing to skyrocket and it
was tough
even my own firm at credit suisse i was
there for a decade after solomon i was
at solomon for eight years
you know a lot of people were like look
you know maybe it's time you just you
know
got off the bearish train because it's
not working
and even when i got vindicated my
vindication was really when new century
um filed for bankruptcy in march of 07.
and that was like the the one pivotal
point where really the stocks had
already gotten killed
back in oh starting july of 05 we
started seeing inventories rising
but it wasn't until really the um back
camp of 05
and into the first half of 006 that the
equities got pummeled
and it was september about six you
mentioned bob toll
because they had a conference call and
he basically said that washington's
getting better
and we're seeing improvement and that's
when i said to him
what kool-aid are you drinking a quote
and yet stocks rallied from september
through
december they probably were up over 40
and i put out a report in december of 06
10 reasons to sell home building stocks
and downgraded all of them i'd been
neutral at that point
and um you know it was not until new
century in march about seven and that
vindication
was really at the the first turning
point i had
that really that was you know sort of
evidence that this was really going to
be
even much way worse than we had thought
but up until then
you know i remember when we did the um
you know the bob toll
uh conference call on the stocks rallied
my one of my um
internal research colleagues was like
you know you really need to
upgrade stocks and not be bearish
anywhere you're going to ruin your
career
and this actually wasn't um somewhere in
research this was the head of product
management
kind of warning me i'm gonna ruin my
career and i went to my director of
research pissed off
and so i stuck to my guns i wasn't easy
i had a good team but it was really the
industry network it was these executives
that are still friendly with many today
that kept me grounded and and my
fundamental analysis was right
i even shared it with the fed i told i
told people at the fed the things that
we had you know showing our slide deck
sending them investors gone wild and
they didn't want to hear it
i wouldn't agree with it back then um
you had this kind of shadow inventory i
remember you tracked the shadow
inventory kind of in real time
um and yet some
other element and this comes back to the
fed there wasn't i'm going back to the
rtc there wasn't this clearing
there never had to be a clearing i i was
i was inside the fed when
when this cottage industry was born
and income the deep pocketed price
agnostic
buyers uh what what effect
did that have then and
looking way out what what effect do you
think it will have ultimately
so you're talking about when the rtc
basically allowed the
you know ability to clear clear the land
that was
no no i'm i'm contrasting single family
rentals
the advent of them coming in you know i
understand that we had a foreclosure
crisis more than 10 million homes
i'm not i'm not insensitive to that but
it was nothing like what it could have
been
correct because you did have free money
at the time you did have the federal
reserve
step in you had the advent of
quantitative easing
zero interest rate policy and now
there's all this money
and this money is moving into phoenix
and the inland empire and the sand
states what we used to call the sand
state so
um elevate sand states right what
what was that like to to see because you
you've
you've been following this industry for
your basically your entire career
and here comes a whole new asset class a
whole new player
right and you know it really when you
think about
um the single-family rental market in
and i remember talking to a property
manager one of my real estate brokers
that
actually managed single-family rental
properties and i was like
oh people live in single family homes
and rent them like it was like a new
concept to me
and so we started really digging in and
he's like well
absolutely in fact i'm a member of the
single family rental property managers
association
and there's 3 500 members and so it
really was
what we called we entitled a research
thematic report called the new old thing
because it really wasn't new but it's
new to the institutional investors
so what we started seeing is
institutional investors that
you know looking at land prices in
phoenix that had pummeled and
you know you could buy land at you know
pennies on the dollar
that were coming in and buying up these
foreclosures at
you know really compelling prices that
were you know really contagious so the
industry
started seeing i remember doing a call
um
with blackstone and jonathan gray was
like do you think that
sfr is a good asset class to contemplate
and i was like absolutely you're buying
below replacement costs so you're buying
all these homes
and not only will you eventually get hpa
but you also can get pretty good cash
and cash returns and we started
realizing
that this was going to be the next
weight this was going to be the
ability for a clearing mechanism for a
lot of the inventory to start to get
acquired and it wasn't just
the institutional investors there were
what we called our reluctant landlords
that couldn't sell their homes that
decided that they could you know be
forced to try to rent them out
and then all of a sudden they were
running them out and they like their
cash on cash returns
so the inventory started getting
acquired and
continued to clear and it was contagious
so the industry
developed into this now very similar
parallels to
what was the mom-and-pop industry in the
multi-family space in the mid to late
90s
became institutionalized we are now in
that institutionalization
of the sfr space and it's still pretty
negligible
when you look at the size of the
industry there's 16 million renters
and only roughly two percent is really
held by institutional investors
so it's concentrated predominantly in
those small states in the sand states
um maybe more like smile because you
think about atlanta atlanta's
a big sfr market um you've got
texas markets across the space the
carolinas
you've got the mountain states nevada
phoenix and of course
in the coast inland uh parts of
california
up to covid we had seen an extraordinary
run
in housing and i think
absent the actual economic cycle itself
one of the reasons was probably that
lending standards were
were the tightest in the history of
mankind
coming out of of the crisis
and that lasted for how long well when
you think about
2009 was officially the first year of a
recovery
and we had a lot of stimulus that was
being thrown at the housing market at
that point
um with the obama administration the
first time buyer tax credit
and we really didn't see improvement
despite affordability being at
at that point an all-time record high so
2009-1011 housing was still
really on its ass it wasn't responding
to record affordability and a lot of
that
came because the mortgage industry had
been arrested
you know it it wasn't allowing so you
can you can have a theoretical
affordability looks great
but if the lenders aren't going to lend
so the credit was very stringent so we
do a proprietary mortgage survey
that captures about 20 of the mortgage
market and we ask on a scale of zero to
one hundred one hundred
you can't get a mortgage zero you can
find a mirror get a mortgage
and 50 is normal where are you on the
underwriting stringency
and i remember that the stringency
peaked at nearly 80 on that index in
2012.
so the the 2009 to 2012 time frame
the stringency actually got more intense
leading up
to dodd-frank's legislation in january
to providing the the rules of engagement
no one trusted the government
no one in the mortgage industry felt
comfortable that they weren't going to
have these loans being put back to them
and the rules are kept changing and
there was a lot of uncertainty and the
mortgage industry didn't like that but
starting in 2013
the credit overlays started coming down
and really continued to
as the industry started getting more
comfortable that home prices were rising
that we now had guard rails because of
qm with cfpb
there was more certainty that the
industry started getting more
competitive but it was really the
non-banks
because the large banks the not the the
banks they didn't want anything to do
with fha
so they're pretty much you talked to
jamie dimon you talked to brian monaghan
they're not going to do fha
so that non-banks really went from 20
market share
to over 60 market share currently so you
went from you know
zero to 100 for non-banks picking up the
slack that the banks weren't willing to
do on fha and fha was really the
the the bulk of the market in terms of
where the industry
with the credit box being so much more
reasonable so really by 2019
the bot that stringency index i referred
to was back to like 54.
and so that's really normal credit box
so the you know you talk to the guys
standing freddie or at fha you see look
these guys are not lending to the full
extent of the box
that we offer so you can go 580 three
and a half percent down
so there was wasn't until really i'd say
19 that all the overlays were gone
completely but then because of kovid
that strangely index
shot up because of forbearance and all
of the
risk then that the mortgage lenders were
starting to the servicers were like holy
crap
and so it's been it's been elevated
still it's kind of at a 62-63 right now
and i think that will change if in fact
we have rates continuing
to back up as inflation which we think
is really rampant
i mean my ecosystem is ridiculous on
fire and every
input cost every piece of the puzzle and
so the idea there's no inflation is just
absolutely nuts from my perspective when
inflation actually materializes and the
fed can't control it
it's your expertise or loses confidence
that they can control it
um i think we're going to see that
there's a lot more
risk that the mortgage lenders will
start to
ease because they're going to need
volume because they've gone out
and aggressively hired to meet this refi
boom
and the purchase boom and they can't
keep up with the demand
and so the spreads have collapsed when
you just look at simplistically
10-year versus 30-year what have been a
spread historically at 165 basis points
going back
30 years trend line by the midst of
covid
when they were all dealing with the
policy to provide forbearance for a year
and the the backlash of that the spread
shot to 270
and now the fret spreads have pummeled
to 155
and that's really a function of them
willing up to give up
their massive gain on sale margins to
continue to see the volume
at high levels they don't want to
they're willing to give up price
so they can sustain volume and if the
industry gets more competitive
because interest rates are backing up
you will see more and more easing on
that stringency
scale that zero 100 that i referred to
so this is where
we get can we cross over into kind of
counter-intuitive land
okay um and some of the parallels that
that take us back to new century and
country-wide and when
volumes were so critical because there
were
i remember my my friend michelle meyer
when she was barely
an economist just a young pup at b of a
and she was like
40 percent of the jobs in america
indirectly and directly are tied somehow
to housing
and the indirectly was a big indirect
but there were still a ton of people
uh who were tied to the housing industry
and if there's one thing that we've
heard in the last
eight nine months it's that this the
area of mortgage lending
in the labor market is just on fire
crazy
absolutely but that has those anecdotes
have have dissipated
in the last few months yeah you don't
hear as much but i'd say that they're
still hiring
um i think you've got a lot of people
that can work at home
remote collections and there's you know
that side of the market with um or the
proportion of the industry that's really
on the servicing side
and collections because of the
forbearance problems that you know right
now are not
really an issue for the for the housing
market with 2.6 million borrowers that
are struggling to make their mortgage so
they're busy
trying to collect so they're still
hiring in that area they're not as much
on the front end but on the
on the servicing side and collections
it's really continuing to see more and
more
hires and i think that the industry is
concerned
um just because as we think about the
commodity aspect of it
i mean you can differentiate all you
want talk about your technology but the
end of the day
you know the consumer is going to look
for the lowest rate and so
uwm which is the largest wholesale
lender
lowered their um rate sheet by one and a
half points and just
like boom we're going to take the volume
and then you have rocket
and then you have all the banks so the
retail the retailers are
the last to lower rates you know
non-banks will go first because they
don't have the same capital position so
it's just fascinating to watch and right
now we're seeing things moving very
quickly
well okay so speaking of quickly um
what was kind of home price by the way
hpa
hpa home price appreciation
what was home price appreciation kind of
when you when it was like the zenith of
the housing boom years
and compare that to where we are today
yeah price appreciation does the home
price appreciation um
really started accelerating 2000 to 2003
and it was really 2004 i think was like
the first big year
and i can't recall if we were nine
percent you know we wound up in
double-digit territory
you know for consecutive years 2005 and
six
um but i think that what i see parallels
today
is that when you think about that level
of you know 2010 2020 finish the year up
and right now just looking at seasonally
adjusted numbers and our proprietary
home building survey
we're looking at 13 14 annualized price
increases seasonally adjusted
and so what i would tell you what's
concerning from our perspective
is that there's a lot of assumptions
going in to
the front end to acquire more land
whether you're building on
the land for for sale or build for rent
that
you have to justify using the same level
of price
that currently is where we are today and
the sales pace
to justify underwriting at today's
inflated land prices there's that that
has a lot of parallels
to what we saw in oh 405 when you were
getting silly and stupid about some of
the underwriting that you just
it didn't pencil and those are things
that we're seeing that are our yellow
flags right now
in the market and i think for the most
part builders
the most interesting thing that we're
seeing is that the demand is so strong
that they are limiting releases of
product because they don't have enough
land
to replace the land that they're cook
their the communities that they're
selling out of
so rather than push on the pace
and and extend their backlog which has
risk because of the inflation and all
the building materials and in labor
they're just stepping on the gas and
raising prices and doesn't that remind
you of 2013
because the builders got so egregious
and 13
and they were limiting releases and they
were stepping on the gas
until guess what we had bernecke and may
go away
and that was when rates shot up 100 bips
and the world stopped
taper tantrum yes taper tantrums so
there are a lot of similarities that
you know we can we can draw and yet you
know the difference though
that i see is that the inventories of
the united states right now
are an all-time record low and the way
we think about inventory is just to put
some quantification around it
is for single family inventory both new
and existing
which is you know majority existing
homes divided by households
so we can look at that ratio and
historically that ratio
call it trend line is two percent and
right now we're closer
and historically back to the previous
boom uh or
uh i should still call the bomb went off
when inventory exploded
we got to almost three and a half
percent
and now we're currently close to 1.1
so we are at an all-time record low and
pre-covered we were at a record low
but that was um surpassed because all
these people pulled their homes off the
market
interestingly they're it's still down
25-30 percent
from where we were pre-coveted so
inventories are so so tight
so there is a need for more production
there is a need for more shelter
but the question is what will the
margins look like and what the
appraisals are showing like the
appraisals are not keeping up
so anyway i'll stop because there's just
so much there and
we are seeing just you know there's so
much fatigue
in the market fatigue from the trades
fatigue
from the supply chain that it's it's
exhausting and they're running at 100
miles an hour
and in my opinion we're running at 100
mile as an hour
and starting to get on dangerous curvy
roads and it's not going to end well
it may not be a great financial crisis
where we're going to have the kind of
crisis we had in 2000
no means in my opinion in 2007-8 but i
do think that there's going to be a lot
of risk for the industry
um and some of the companies that are
getting a little bit
loose you know fast and easy again
so a lot of that inventory disappeared
and at the same time
you had a big chunk of a generation move
in with their parents
so i mean what's to say
i mean italy does it a lot of countries
do it
but do you foresee in terms of headship
rates do you foresee
uh kind of a sustainability
of multiple generations living
underneath one roof
you know i think that um the data
suggests that there was a lot of
young adults aged 18 to 34 that
despite being 34 people are surprised to
hear that that actually did leave
their you know having their rentals and
moving back in with their their
families and while unemployment surged
during covid
that really surged alongside of it we've
started to see that
um wayne a bit as we are seeing young
adults leaving their families to go back
into cities
and start renting again i have two
associates 27
that lived with their families in
livingston new jersey alex and jesse
call out to them
and they're now back in the city and by
the way they got great deals on the new
on the rentals oh yeah one in hudson
yards like 25
below where it was pre-covered so good
for jesse uh
on bottom ticket but i so i think we're
gonna see
um not a snapback but we're gonna see
those that are employed
that were working remotely that went to
live with their parents you'll see that
decoupling
but you know we still have many borrow
many many young people that are out of
work
so whether they're in hospitality
leisure entertainment or travel
all those things all those you know jobs
that unfortunately coveted
um you know resulted in them being
unemployed
how quickly those industries come back
but you know if you're living at home
um and you're doing well and you're
productive you know how many employers
are going to let you to continue to do
so
um i think you're going to see that work
from home which back pre-covered
um was call it in the mid single digits
um there's
studies that are saying that it can go
to 15 to 20 percent
so i think that household formations we
think
relative to the housing vacancy data
just overall
census bureau data we are much more
negative on household formations for
what occurred in 2020
we estimate only 900 000 actually
uh incremental households were formed
and that compares to kind of running at
a million three million four
because it's you know consolidation that
you refer to
um 21 at this point you know it's tough
to say what the number will be but it
will be below that one three one four
which is a lot of what you know the
overall housing industry is dependent
upon when they're looking at well we're
such in a deficit of supply
because there's only two components to
really determining the need
or how much supply we need household
formation
plus demolition so if household
formations are not going to be one three
one four
and demolitions kind of run in this few
hundred call it two to three hundred
range then you're gonna see that we're
building at the expectations for a
million five we need when maybe we don't
need a million five
so at some point we're gonna over build
we're not overbuilt yet
but i would say that we're going to
within the next few years i could see
that we would be
um oversupplied again so it's going to
be interesting to watch
yeah here in dallas i figured the final
excerpt is going to be you know across
the red river and
inside of oklahoma time they're all
finally said and done
um so there has been
something else that you've also never
seen in your career there are a lot of
2020 word was unprecedented
this mass exodus
out of the densely populated
urban centers you you've even got a camp
you've got a term that you the great
reshuffle
yes um talk to us about
where we might be given
i i looked i looked at a map of the
united states yesterday and mobility is
increasing in all 50 states plus dc
you've got basically green lights every
even california
is starting to i mean disney's going to
open up for god's sake i mean we're like
well i can see the finish line
uh so where do you see us as being in
that cycle and talk
also about this wave of second home
purchases
right well first on the great american
shuffle what we should all recognize
actually even before the great american
shuffle let's talk about the flight from
urban
to suburban to excerpt what we have been
uh witnessing and reporting on is that
that trend had been well underway
really starting in 2015. and a lot of it
was predicated because of millennials
were becoming
of age to get married family so
lifestyle
really was already accelerating the
flight from the urban
core to the a suburban and even more so
what we call
the excerpts this is the third furthest
ring
and so if you look at an index that we
have called a gdi index
and we love indexes so a zero is the
most rural
you know out in oklahoma that's your
zero and 100 is new york city
and so when you look at this index and
look at where the adult population lives
from 2012 to 2019
pre-covered we had a 45 point drop
in the above 45 plus on that index
and a 27 point increase in the zero to
zero
nine or two to nine so that that
that continuum was already showing this
shift and it was because the number of
people that are age 35 to 44
which is really that cohort that is
going to more likely be
married with a family that in 2017
is going from a trough of quality 40
million
and by the end of this decade 2030
be 48 million so as compared to the 25
to 40 25 to 34
is peaked in 2014 and has been
decelerating so it's a lot to do with
the underpinnings of the demographics
that started this urban
or the de-urbanization now you get
covet so all of a sudden you've got
young couples that might have thought
they're going to live in the city for a
few years
they haven't started their family yet
but that we've pulled forward people
leaving
but more importantly we haven't had the
incremental
people moving into cities that you
normally have
so the combination of the two to the
pull forward of those
leaving to you know flight for you know
more space flight to you know safety and
having their own backyard
was magnified by the lack of people
coming into cities
but the great american shuffle has been
underway for very long time
going back really looking at just this
prior decade for example
we estimate although the decennial
survey is not completed
that households grew about nine percent
in it from 2010
to 2020. if you look at the
red states predominantly you know we'll
look at texas
arizona nevada um idaho
utah in those states including florida
grew
anywhere from 18 to 20 percent and so
then you look at the flip side with a
lot of our blue states california new
york new jersey connecticut
illinois ohio growing at two to three
percent
and so that great american shuffle was
well underway
now you get covet and mobility rates
interestingly you mentioned that
if you look at just just simplistically
just take 2 000 mobility rate
and compare the mobility rate to where
we were at 2018
you were down about 400 basis points
so we were seeing that people had
historically because boomers
which are very important cohort um
bigger than millennials roughly
and also more importantly much bigger
from the incremental change from the
prior generation
they age in place so you know i'm 54
and um i have been living in the same
home for 15 years and we're not planning
on going anywhere so the older we get
nine percent of the people that are
between the ages of 50 and 54
move in a given year when you're 20 to
53 move so we have an aging population
which tends to age in place which is why
mobility was under pressure
plus because of the great uh financial
crisis
a lot of people lost so much equity in
their homes and they
didn't have enough equity to trade up so
discretionary move-ups
were just really um lackluster which was
another reason why
inventory was not after the the great
grab from all the investors and the eye
buyers you've got
you've got so much so much demand
beyond primary buyers that inventory
cleared
and hasn't been coming back because the
lack of discretionary upgrades because
of the aging population and also people
locked in
at low mortgage rates thanks to our our
fed policy back during the great
financial crisis
and and qe that people were like i'm not
moving rates are so low i'm
disincentivized so a lot of that kept
the inventory so tight for this cycle um
and as a result of that people really
weren't moving
then you bring covet in and now mobility
is accelerating
and we're starting to see people are
going um to all of these
great affordable red states and they're
not only better
more affordable but they've got um
better climates in many cases so you see
you're seeing that shuffle that i refer
to
2010 to 2020 just on steroids now
so you mentioned baby boomers
we've been studying the labor force
participation rate and
for 55 plus the labor force
participation rate peaked out at around
1960.
then you had this long huge decline
that perked up basically with the
dot-com bust
so you start to see this rise up off
these lows
in the labor force participation rate
for those 55 plus it got up to about 40
percent and stayed there
it's hovered there for a good 10 years
that's been one of the most that's been
one of those consistent
increasing cohorts into the labor force
because for whatever reason longer
longer life expectancy they couldn't
leave the workforce their portfolios
blew up not once but twice blah blah in
the past
post covid if you will we've seen that
come crashing down to the lowest since
2007.
wow so of the people and and we have not
seen that in other age groups the other
age cohorts are being reabsorbed
back into the workforce but we are
finally seeing
baby boomers instead of retiring in
theory
retiring in practice
so given where the stock market is today
is that a potential area that could
loosen up
inventory in coming years
we hope so i mean the expectation is
that we'll see inventory loosening up
because people are you know the graying
of america the retirees
moving from you know the cold climates
to more favorable climates
you know inventory you also would expect
to rise as it's a seller's market
people are recognizing that their home
values have gone up considerably
and so i we we keep saying inventory is
going to start increasing because people
are going to recognize
in a post code world when they're no
longer concerned of their safety they've
been vaccinated
they feel like they can finally make the
decision there's also a lot of pent-up
demand
from a mobility perspective that people
are awaiting what their
firm's policies going to be so i was on
the phone yesterday with an exec
professional at goldman sachs who has
three children lives in the city
and you know she's waiting to know
whether or not
they're gonna allow for her to commute
maybe one or two days a week and she's
gonna then move out to long island so
she's waiting
and i think there are a lot of people
waiting because if you ask firms their
policy they have yet to determine
and finalize what they're going to allow
their talent
to do yeah but i see plenty of people on
trading desks who've been
you know out in westchester county this
whole time and you know
they haven't you know they haven't
skipped a beat yeah and by the same
token
you've seen an extraordinary pickup in
second home purchases
right i didn't mention the second home
second homes are off the charts and why
not
we have free money thanks to jay you
know the the world has been
great you know so great to those that
can afford to buy a second home
because the stock markets also had in
euphoria so we've got a wealth creation
the wealth gap between the the haves and
have-nots
thanks to j-pal and qe or every measure
that have
resulted in stock markets euphoria and
liquidity is only
fueling more second homes now i don't
know if you saw yesterday fannie and
freddie
came out and basically capped that
they're only willing to do up to seven
percent
second homes now as part of their um
loans that they'll purchase
so they're recognizing there's more risk
so that should
start to maybe reduce or diminish some
of that
fueling but there's so much above the
fannie freddie loan limit
you know going on so you would think
that that would be predominantly jumbos
anyway i think it i think it is i think
it's more jumbo
but just even them capping it is sort of
a recognition that there's more risk
associated with that but i think that
there
the jumbo market for second homes right
now
magnitude wise is probably at or above
the prior peak levels we we haven't seen
this level of demand
and i think you know it's going to
continue contingent on rates 100
100 and the stock market but but really
thinking about
you know today's um second home buyer is
taking advantage of the ability to work
remote
having more flexibility so it's a very
positive story from a secular
perspective the work from home phenomena
so um
i'm going to throw out an accounting
term here last in first
out there is some concern uh
we've spoken offline in the past few
weeks and the
fha delinquency rate peaked at 14.4
percent
uh after the great financial crisis 17
today severe delinquencies are at 11.8
percent
um i realize this is too big of a
question to ever answer for anybody for
policymakers for politicians for bankers
for
for for for fannie freddie but what
happens
what happens to a lot of these buyers
who've come in
what 40 50 60 of them need down payment
assistance
um so what is kind of the solution
especially against the backdrop of
runaway home prices when you've got
a lot of new buyers in homes that they
might not be able to afford so if you're
janet yellen i mean
how how crafty you're going to scare me
now but how creative can that woman get
well first realizing that the fact that
home prices have inflated so much
really enables a lot of these homeowners
that are struggling
to possibly sell their homes and and pay
off their mortgage and not be underwater
so that you know is gonna really be a
savior to many
so what we're seeing right now with
servicers is that
they're going to continue to allow
borrowers to be modified through
september
right and then game over i don't think
so
not under this administration they'll
just extend it and kick the can
and a lot of those people you would hope
are going to get back to work
the other thing that the administration
is contemplating right now is a
first-time buyer tax credit for 15 000
for those that qualify would have it
advanceable and permanent
so that will juice up housing even more
and you also have the dreamers so
roughly 800 000
dreamers that will be eligible for fha
financing
and we also have student loan
forgiveness that is being contemplated
that would also help for those that make
less than 125 000
they're contemplating 10 000 of student
loan forgiveness so they've got a lot on
the table
whether any of those will come to
fruition is debatable but i think that
right now the struggling borrowers
the best thing that they have going for
them is really the fact that home
prices have inflated so much um actually
there are companies today
that will allow you to sell and stay
so basically you sell your home and they
will rent you
you'll you'll rent the home back and so
you get the equity so you can't qualify
for
a cash out refi because you're
unemployed but if you want to do
um a sell and stay with some of these
startups like a company called easy
knock you can do that
so there's ways to get around losing
your home
but for the most part there's so much
demand danielle
from the eye buyers the sfr buyers
the fix and flip buyers that there is
literally a starvation of her inventory
so because we both know that
foreclosures and judicial states having
lived through the pig and the python
coming out of the great recession it's
not going to all come at once
and we're not going to see a flood of
foreclosures it would be very much
similar to what we had through the great
financial crisis so i think the
the market can absorb inventory it's
just for those people that would be
unfortunately in a situation where
they're forced to sell
and whatever consolidate move back with
family members or friends
or move to a more affordable shelter um
it's unfortunate if it comes to that but
i don't think it's going to create
sort of a a collapse in home prices by
any means
so then so what does
what will your first yellow true
you've seen a few yellow flags what what
because
we don't have a confluence of craziness
there's not the credit rating agencies
and the fed and
the underwriting and the cdos and i mean
it's not everywhere in your face
at all and this is this is totally
different you you have to more than fog
a mirror
to get a mortgage but what what what do
you think will be kind of your first
red flag if you had to look into your
crystal ball which nobody likes to do
um but but but going out into 2021
given i mean just the sheer heat
throwing off
of all risky assets the stock market and
the fact that we're about to pump
a few trillion dollars into the economy
a lot of which i think is going to go
into services spending
well you know whether we think about the
risk to
sort of home price inflation and think
about the things that
concern us you know we look at the
number of homeowners in the united
states that have been the beneficiary
of you know record low rates to refi and
improve their balance sheets so if you
look at a 30-year fixed rate
at below five five percent it's shocking
that
um 23 of americans that own a home have
a rate above five percent
still and when i look at those that are
um that own a home that i have a
mortgage rate below four percent
is 49 currently so the reason i
i frame that is because i'm wondering
who are the people that are above four
percent today
and it's funny i was actually talking
with a girlfriend last night that lives
on long island
and where i grew up and she is at 4.6
and i'm like are you out of your mind
why haven't you refined you live under a
rock you don't realize rates are low
she's like i'm just so busy no one else
is going to take all the data and there
aren't the closing costs expensive
so she was like my one anecdote of
someone that lives under a rock
you know that didn't realize you can
rebuy and save yourself a lot of money
but for those people that have been um
you know savvy enough to refi
the 49 that are below four and there's
roughly 22 percent below
three and a half and we start to look at
those people
what's going to happen if we get a
mortgage rate at four and a half percent
they're not going anywhere they're not
going anywhere and so i think that to me
will will really stop the music in the
discretionary upgrades for those that
are not
what i call the affordability busters
those that are leaving those high-cost
states to go to
low-cost states that won't care if
mortgage rates are four and a half
percent because
they have such a arbitrage so i think
that
that will be a wrinkle to sort of
understand the implications
but you know one of the things that you
call a yellow flag or not but think
about
you know whether you're in dallas like
yourself and you think about all the
local buyers
that are getting shut out because of all
of those
affordability busters that are coming
into their local markets like
austin from the people from silicon
valley they're kind of making a new mini
silicon valley in austin now or if
you're in any parts of florida from all
the new yorkers that have come
people from chicago are going into all
of these
sunbelt states so it's making it much
more harder for the very borrower or
potential prospective buyer
that the administration wants to help
for the people to reduce this inequality
gap
we're actually throwing gas on the fire
and it may actually accelerate that
inequality gap right and in the meantime
you're going to have
mass amounts of multi-family high-rises
that i saw some extraordinary number of
units that are coming online this year
in new york i'm like
who is going to absorb that i mean this
this is this we're not even talking
about on the market yet
right uh and yet you've had this massive
trend
so i mean presumably the younger ones
are going to come into the cities again
they have to i think so i think so the
in the multi-family market
benefited from what we call the wall of
capital
that really chased that asset class as
as many referred to it as the tallest
within commercial real estate
because it certainly it was
outperforming office retail other
segments
oh gosh yes and yet that wall of capital
has resulted
it's predominantly in the urban core the
backlog
of units that will that need to be
completed is at multi-decade highs
and it's predominantly in those urban
core markets where demand is
pummel and you have this you know
perfect storm
of incremental supply that still needs
to be absorbed so i think that it's
going to be very attractive for renters
because prices are still going to be
under pressure and it's just going to
make it more compelling for them to
actually
potentially young people come into the
city after being for so
long so expensive to live in in
some of the great cities of our country
well that's promising
if i was 25 years younger but um
it's all it's all good it's all good um
all right so i have i have one last
question one
i just a friend of mine uh she named her
boys
uh identically uh so that she didn't
have to
she's from louisiana very southern very
southern you are not very southern ivy
but she named her boys so that they
would have all the same initials so that
she could use everything that she'd
monogrammed
so i i have to ask zoey zachary and zaya
z and zayashi what's with the z's
well i think i mean this is amazing z
squared these kids are all z squared
they're all z z squared so um when we
were
pregnant with zoe um i love the name zoe
and um given that um my our last name is
zellman
you know it sounded cool and then when
we had zach
our middle one it was he was going to be
either nicole or zach
and so when we we had zach we said you
know let's just stick with the z theme
and so we kind of made up zia we're
looking at playing with names and what
rhymes with
mia ozia i remember that one and i
actually have an australian shepherd
named zilli so after a store
so we just like disease so it's been uh
it does get confusing though because
i'll call
you know each kid by each other's name
and i actually call my youngest daughter
z
um and or zia bia and um
it's a lot of fun well okay now
that that mystery is solved for me so um
so let's let's do this again in 12
months because uh
your world right now is moving faster
than my world and that's saying
something
so i'd love to get back together in
about about another 12 months and
revisit maybe you'll be in your other
home but
for the sake of all of us stay out there
in newport beach enjoy the sun
great visiting with you and i hope to
see you in person
at some point in in 2021 that would be
great take good care
thank you daniel it's great to have
being on youtube well i don't know about
you but uh i'm a huge
fan of the housing market ivy is the
guru of all gurus when it comes to
housing
we know it's something that's front and
center for so many people right now
because home prices have taken off as
much as they are
so tread lightly you are you are playing
in a market right now that is at
all-time highs just like the stock
market
and if you're interested in my views on
other asset classes uh i
just just just did an interview with
adam sosnick if you missed it
please watch it it's fun there's
actually day drinking
involved i'm not kidding and if you
haven't subscribed please go ahead and
do so
and i look forward to the next time we
meet for down the middle
thank you bye
you